si eso es muy buenos días Pues como
ustedes lo decía partido sin a goles y
bastante parejo en realidad entre
Croacia y Marruecos a pesar de que los
africanos se fueron mucho mejores tal
vez en ese segundo tiempo con
el jugador que se desarrolla actualmente
en el país
trató por todos los medios de abrir el
marcador en este partido pero imposible
Y la verdad es que ya hacia el final En
todo caso este segundo tiempo pues ya
los ambos equipos digamos desecharon
para atrás estaban tratando ya de cuidar
En todo caso ese resultado y sobre todo
bueno Croacia en general en los dos
últimas veces que había enfrentado un
equipo africano había ganado por ahora
quedan en ceros Pero eso sí ambos
equipos venían invictos y continúan y
invictos así que por ahora pues este 0
por 0 y según las estadísticas que
tenemos de este mundial pues este ya es
el de los últimos cuatro partidos que se
han disputado aquí en Qatar Ya son tres
que terminan sin goles